yeah I came to this video and plain
lucky against the spear week neck raspy
oh I probably butcher this up badly from
the Netherlands until we got an advance
talk on let's see a three yeah there are
moves amazing yeah well II six is
probably a good reply
mmm a three maybe I can try to combine
this attack on b2 with preparing c5 and
not see 50 mi opening up the position
too quickly yeah but it looks it looks
rather logical to to get get this in
quickly after a three and this also
allows the night to go to c6 and not to
d7 quite quite often you need to be
cautious with opening up the position
and have to start with 97 97 and only
play see five later and now I I played
that very quickly ok let's see 6
increase the pressure yeah I expect them
to take on 1c5
to reach Keller here it's always been
this way okay so he played before and I
wonder if I can just take on c2 on if
that is some that is a mistake Bishop b5
hear a but still if I don't take what
what sense does this justice make just
just grab it okay the question is where
to go with the bishop may be here try to
exchange it if it takes I will get a 5
and this I should I think should make
sure that I get this Bishop exchanged
yep come on let's let's keep it simply
here
k he retreats yeah why not d 5 & a 5
immediately attacking this weakness yeah
I don't see how he defends a 3 really
you can play okay one but this is a
returnable now let's grab this as well
so I'm two points up no reason not to
take really I have nine I to the aid
check
okay knight c6 is not threatened so i
can keep the deeper be five pound white
reason why my next move was just castles
i still can't castle and then i'm out of
it yeah he simply misplayed this opening
i think not not sure a a 3s bit slow but
shouldn't be needing to trouble but here
black is already quick here in white
cannot really play move like as he three
let's have a look at this briefly
instead of taking if you would place III
i mean it's it's an excellent French
with the bishop on f5 and there's always
this idea it's not working at the moment
because of the capture on c5 but this is
an additional idea I can I can probably
just develop here and see what is coming
up with looks are very nice after the
capture though yes this is a big problem
see to how do you defend it if you place
something like this I cannot think about
these kind of ideas on this one
attacking two crucial points yeah an a3
is probably too slow and leading to to
slide trouble and to the way it went
this was just the pawn and they're not
oops not the non important point this d
5 is a protected passport so blankets am
just winning here alright thanks for
watching